my manly the other side of mustaches
this is deliberate
you have a beard
outdoors killing animals that's a choice
you wear on your face I can't grow
because I'd love to be a more manly guy
I take this I still in this no problem
now because I'm adjusting I'd love to be
a little more man in certain things for
example I'd like to be the kind of guy
who when the phone rings I could answer
it go that guy my own carrying tank top
my living room working on a carburetor
why in my limo
I can't grow beer that's the fun I love
to be able to grow they're not I don't
want to hear I don't want that I want
the option if I'm never on playground if
any of us matter on a plane crash am to
live on like a deserted island run six
years it's a right of man and passage
when that rescue chopper comes to emerge
from the rush uj-- happen Moses beer
no grab me a beer you anymore I own
design things especially I want not me
I'm their CTU's rescue chopper come
tonight come out in a loincloth baby
face I look like a guy who's been there
two days wait to wear